[Music]
hello everybody today we are doing
another challenge we are doing the
dress-up challenge and shout out to four
four versus girlfriendy originated this
challenge brought to them yeah I know
we're so excited looking forward to this
challenge because when they did it was
14 hilarious they were like we're you
gotta do is to it's also like kind of
building it up a little bit more for the
wedding day getting you guys prepared
this is our shared experience of a
wedding game with you guys yeah I mean
we're making it a wedding games because
the wedding is coming up you know what
we should do we should do this challenge
again after the wedding and then you
wear my wedding dress and I'll wear your
suit I'm gonna rip your wedding dress
no it's okay I mean I'm only gonna wear
that one day could if you guys really
want to watch that comment down below
let us know and you guys would be down
and watch a part two to the dress up
challenge with our wedding stuff does
it's open
say goodbye to your wedding dress when
you go to my Chinese dress because I
bought it a red Chinese dress for two
ceremony and you can now if you're like
I need to buy like a mariachi like I
don't know like a Mexican wedding suit
whatever that was or Mexicans are so
Westerners like we don't really have the
whole thing maybe I might ask you unless
you're from like potential can I do one
of those no no okay fine but anyway
we're going to get started we're going
to do three looks today a workout look a
casual look and a going-out look alright
so first up we have workout clothes I
have this is what I would wear softener
and what is this I know it's clean
yes you're not wearing dirty laundry
dryer thing the dryer sheet dryer sheet
yeah I wouldn't go like that one comfy
Enzo hat this is what I wear too far
though so horrible hat anywhere I like
that no Mexicans wears like super high
up and then this is a Barbeau tank top
and into something very special
do I even have to spend a lot on my Mac
done you look like you're ready for a
rap video however your ride back all
right go for it here we go
[Music]
hi the funny I really like it yeah oh if
you like you could put your tops on our
face right now as well ferritin the high
ponytail I think I can't put the have
even lower side flip the broom execute a
copy of my nerd wear your clothes I
don't know why my gosh and I really
really would a boyfriend stuff I do I
never wear so you know my first started
dating you did leave that white shirt at
my house oh yeah yes and then I really
wear that tonight repin and when I
missed you over two million and stuff
you would smell it so your figure
collage it's not really good go to my
father's and I know and I have you I
don't need your shirt are you ready for
your outfit my office can we be here
ready yeah all right here we have oh my
lord
bra from pop black Thank You Blogilates
she helps me up with some her amazing
gear I love this stuff it's like such
good quality and it's so cute she likes
an angle or cell phone room and these
pants they're super super cute it has
like mesh on the sides and I mean they
don't rip it
okay please these are okay I think I
think oh gosh red to that much I'm
telling you I love this stuff don't rip
any of this yes thank you oh mediate
while I'm putting this on actually oh
just don't rip any of it please I will
try not to thank you
are you ready yes is a lot more
embarrassing than I thought it was going
to be ah I can't wait show me show me
show me this is crazy
I can't I can't even a continuance of my
my shoulders absolutely I'm going to be
ready oh yeah three two one oh my gosh
so oh really how do you bend it this is
good I do it's cutting on through love
uncle took me forever to fold it up at
certain points and then it took me
forever to it's so sad what's going on
here is it Presta to him just so if I
don't push it over yeah but it's so
funny oh my god weapon look I wish you
had concealed clothes all his hair is so
gross oh wow don't like I don't like
everything it doesn't even feel good to
let go of my shoulders if you're like
I'm just stuff like this right now pop
like that is really stretchy it is
durable yes it is who rocked it there
hurt olala
or my Blogilates or gut look I think you
win I feel like you could literally walk
out in the streets and know whatever bed
and I might add weird okay I don't know
why you win all right so next round
can't go where yeah oh I got you another
hat yeah my hat puts it over to
Greenacre and then we've got some pestle
and mortar and then you actually bought
me these shores recently so yeah and
then about Japan you need it I probably
will if you will thank you yes you're
welcome
look at the kitty cat you guys are
joining us huh joining us while we're
changing
I really don't like any different L&T
anywhere teaches all the time anyway
ready yeah right crazy wonder look any
different actually just like you need to
let me give me this belt because it's
not I would have you would absolutely
sure you'll take it you still
oligotrophic it's holding on to it that
actually look just kidding what kind of
troll I don't even know when I was
younger a milk boy is always messing
around my friend crystal we could be
like to do this I think we could pretend
of you're drunk I don't know why we did
that we're still Mexican oh my gosh I'm
anything I'm so comfortable I'm saying
ya guys are so lucky we have to wear
this stuff going to 10 min I want to do
this right now
you know you're a figure out finish yes
I'm ready to get a bit hopefully the
next one is more comfortable and this is
the workout clothes to it this is
supposed to be more comfortable and no
oh go through your you're enjoying this
a little too much okay working alright
baby outfit okay okay you go buddy
what in a hatch yeah this is my nice
little hat and you can use and then have
a really cute shirt that I got a hmm and
like it and Andy's pants
so I got these days a while back that I
asked having bought two biggest things
get me really big so I never wear these
and I really hope they thin and because
photo giving you my normal Kings I don't
think he meant one foot would even go
through here you go there goes my taking
like 20 minutes to get in no actually
I've been saving a chance for when I get
really really really big okay I get you
pregnant
aka pregnant yeah try to do it this is
like super histor I don't dress hipster
yeah see mr. Arno
what's number two oh crap it is like an
ultra v-neck that all take a sketch mr.
ultra mean it you will no longer look
like a do take two 100 children I like
this dad makes me feel like a pre
qualitative tackle for the army the
military
dad good what happened oh my gosh it's
again if you're tight okay those are ago
I need a one-for-one thank you
I need a bra this is no good you see
your nipples how are you yeah wherever
it isn't more of like this girl word
popped up with this and I can't move it
around you need one last final touch
there we go oh my gosh you're still
thinking our a/c is turned off at the
moment because they're opening our roof
and they're reaching boiling everything
for the behalf turn off the a/c so it's
invariably not complete during this
mothering I'm getting Aries too I think
they're still pierced oh yeah so we're
airing them all rights all ready for my
outfit they're going out outfit going
out outfit spread out this is from wolf
and man they actually sent this to me a
couple months ago I heading for
Christmas it was like a Christmas
present for me oh yeah I like your stuff
actually I have really good some banks
wolf and man you dress him up so nice we
send more because I love your stuff
better than judo from this now I want to
see you okay
is for right now yeah the whole pants
and pants not man cat okay other guys
okay-dokey
ah look he looks like Olivia rabbit and
I out one button so I have a pretty good
cleavage right here right down all right
ready yes three two one go back go back
oh it's like that's like supposed to be
like a tighter shirt I know every
passage is so tight actually fits me
pretty good
baggy I can wear these though like if I
wanted to wear like really banging Dave
actions to be the little legwork pantry
or something yeah yeah I'll touch on it
just my ray-bans oh you can go into
going out to eat all I got every outfit
you wear it you look like the toes you
know what I'll do if you actually did it
and we blend out the very top one I'm
going to leave it loose with a you see
my whole broad everything's only
managers well I want to do that this is
so sweaty like a fan for the shoulders
Amanda my shoulder feels great doing so
psyche but we're so ridiculous
okay you ready for your goai not have to
it this is actually more coffee than the
previous one for me although is it
getting more comfy maybe huh whooshing
oh not okay okay right oh yeah
so this dress I got from this robot
boutique she sent it over and I freaking
love it so much it's like super stretchy
okay it's really like form-fitting and
then I have this purse from Dagny Dover
I think the save an outfit to the clutch
will not really a purse or a person
coaches coaches Christmas I don't know
but you know what I mean so speak a
different language general I just know
what I like things and that's it I don't
know what they are properly called but
this is it just yeah I want to be doing
this you're gonna look so hot
oh my gosh II yeah over here nice and
comfy while you're suffering over ah
weird wrong all right this is ever the
best one yet or the worst one yet I
don't know which one is which
oh I can't walk forward be careful is
over big Sid Levin dress I still haven't
learned a chance to wear it to anything
yet so don't don't grab it please okay
try not to is it really great to what
you guys give us a little twirl hey
you're so good what happened you can
admit no feeling is going to real and I
was thinking oh but you did this so you
lift it around here yeah because at
least I could do it didn't I scoop it
fall out
oh yeah boom out the pack I got that I'm
just kind of know where your how you
just embracing all of this is modeling
and torquing and pulling you're talking
this my knees are stuck together close
my make up really yeah because it's like
really really technically to go on a
date honey right you wait for this okay
you're like speaking Hindi voice
actually speaking in underseater all
right guys thank you so much for
watching our dress up challenge video
hope you guys had a good time you know
what I'm moving his arms because he
keeps pulling my hair last video you
know it's funny we actually mentioned
that in that video and then you couldn't
out thinking it wasn't necessary but
then people like to speculate and uh she
doesn't want to see cases love no you're
just saying I love to pulling my hair
okay anyway thank you guys for watching
this video let us know who rocked it
better obviously he did come on alright
thank you so much for watching our dress
up challenge video is that girl a
goodbye you are trooper thank you you're
so did you see this dress gonna shake
the dry cleaners it's like drench them I
still haven't worn that dress you know
it's funny too is I had to take off my
underwear to fly this dress oh yeah take
this dress in the game is designed for
the guy to lose and how are you wanted
fun
[Music]